"Третя хвиля" пандемії COVID-19 накрила більшість країн Європи.
Уряди ЄС експериментують з різноманітними карантинними обмеженнями, аби зупинити стрімке поширення мутацій.
Комендантська година, жорсткий локдаун, м’який локдаун, локдаун вихідного дня… Чи справді ефективні такі обмеження?
DW проаналізувала досвід різних країн.
Коли торік навесні Італію накрила перша хвиля коронавірусу, саме жорсткий локдаун допоміг зупинити
стрімке поширення вірусу і перевантаженість медичних закладів.
На думку багатьох епідеміологів, краще радикальний локдаун на 2-3 тижні, ніж розтягнуті на місяці напівзаходи.
Однак головним недоліком суворого локдауну є повна зупинка соціального й економічного життя,
що в свою чергу тягне за собою також низку психологічних проблем.
Тому після досвіду жорстких локдаунів навесні минулого року під час другої хвилі пандемії восени уряди схилялися
радше до м'яких або гібридних локдаунів. Візьмімо Німеччину.
Тут уже з листопада не працюють заклади громадського харчування, готелі, спортивні, розважальні, культурні заклади.
Перукарні були закриті цілих три місяці.
Роботодавців закликали перевести своїх працівників всюди, де можливо, на віддалену роботу - хоум-офіс, аби зменшити ризик інфікування на роботі.
Завдяки цим заходам Німеччині взимку вдалося утримати ситуацію з коронавірусом під контролем та запобігти перевантаженню лікарень.
Однак досягти бажаних показників з новими інфекціями німці так і не змогли.
І тепер розмірковують про можливість нового суворішого локдауну.
На думку експертів, проблема гібридних локдаунів часто у тому, що в багатьох країнах місцева влада сама вирішувала, що дозволяти і що забороняти.
Тож, виходило, що в межах однієї держави могли діяти абсолютно різні обмеження. Відповідно й ефект від них був "клаптиковий".
У Франції, Італії, Іспанії, Нідерландах, Великобританії, Португалії та низці інших країн діяла чи діє досі комендантська година.
Головний аргумент прихильників цього обмеження - більшість заражень відбуваються через приватні контакти -
зустрічі з друзями чи родичами, які можна скоротити завдяки забороні виходити з дому після 20-ої або 22-ої.
Різні дослідження вказують, що комендантська година може бути ефективна, але лише у поєднанні з іншими обмежувальними заходами.
Приміром, як засвідчили різні комп'ютерні симуляції, коли в тій чи іншій країні спостерігається значний сплеск нових заражень,
комендантська година є дієвим доповненням до локдауну.
Цікавий досвід щодо цього зібрала канадська провінція Квебек, яка в грудні-січні особливо потерпала від коронавірусу.
Тоді тут запровадили комендантську годину з 8-ї вечора і до 6 ранку.
Відтоді ситуація з пандемією у Квебеку стабільна або навіть покращується, тоді як в інших канадський провінціях навпаки погіршується.
Разом з тим комендантська година, запроваджена уже з 6-ої чи 7-ої вечора, засвідчила себе як малоефективна або й навіть з негативними наслідками.
Як приклад наводять Францію. Рання комендантська година дуже часто призводила тут до черг у супермаркетах,
скупчень людей навколо полиць з продуктами і недотримання соціальної дистанції.
Адже французи намагалися встигнути закупитися після роботи приблизно в один і той же час, і це створювало додаткові ризики для нових заражень.
Критики нарікають, що ВООЗ досі не представила якихось авторитетних досліджень щодо того,
наскільки вагомим фактором у поширенні вірусу є діти.
На початку пандемії вважалося, що вірус не дуже чіпляється до дітей.
Потім - що чіпляється, але діти часто переносять його безсимптомно.
Про нинішні ж мутації кажуть, що вони особливо стрімко поширюються саме серед дітей.
Небезпека у тому, що діти, повертаючись із шкіл чи дитсадків додому, створюють сімейні осередки зараження.
На перший погляд, найпростіший вихід - просто закрити школи і перевести навчання в онлайн режим.
Але питання - як довго може функціонувати дистанційне навчання? Наскільки це якісна освіта?
І які психологічні наслідки для дітей матиме тривале обмеження соціальних контактів?
Тож, уряди нерідко вдаються до так званого гібридного навчання.
Приміром, у Німеччині класи розділили навпіл, щоб за партою сиділа лише одна дитина, групи по черзі ходять до школи:
в один день або тиждень - одна половина класу, в інший - друга.
Також німці запровадили тестування школярів на коронавірус двічі на тиждень, аби якомога швидше виявляти випадки зараження серед учнів.
Уряди країн виправдовуються: якби не мутації коронавірусу, пандемію б уже вдалося приборкати.
Мовляв, нові мутації більш заразні й стійкі, тому незважаючи на обмеження рівень захворюваності не падає,
а в багатьох країнах навіть зростає попри прихід весни і потепління.
Фактично нині між вірусом і людством йде змагання у швидкості, кажуть експерти.
Або людство встигне вакцинуватися, виробити колективний імунітет і тим самим перервати ланцюжок поширення зарази.
Або вірус мутує настільки, що нинішні щеплення вже не будуть ефективними проти нього
і доведеться починати все з початку та розробляти нову вакцину.
Аби завадити цьому, радники уряду ФРН нині схиляються до такого сценарію:
запровадити на 2-3 тижні жорсткий локдаун, після цього подовжити дію комендантської години,
щоб довше зберегти позитивний ефект від жорстких обмежень.
За цей час наростити темпи вакцинації і тестувань.
Зрештою ані комендантська година, ані локдаун самі по собі - не панацея у боротьбі з коронавірусом.
Потрібні комплексні дії разом з масовими щепленнями, збільшенням тестів і відповідно раннім виявленням вірусу та ізоляцією хворого,
а також більш злагодженою роботою центральної влади з регіонами.